if the u.s or the uk
wanted to extend the 31st
of august deadline in order to
[Music]
continue evacuations out of the country
would you agree to that no no why not
the
this is something
you can say it's a red line president
biden
announced
this agreement that until
31st of august they would withdraw all
their military forces
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation while there is no
need for for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will
create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will
provoke reaction
let's talk about the situation at the
airport people are very afraid of what
life may look like under your rule
people are prepared to leave everything
behind they're prepared to risk their
lives to leave the country
what would be your message to them
first i assure you it is not about their
worry
and not about their scare there this is
about
the they want their demand to resettle
in western countries
and that is a kind of
economic migration because afghanistan a
poor country and 70 percent of the
people of afghanistan are living under
the line of poverty so everyone wants to
settle in western countries to have a
prosperous life
so the the that is
it is not about scared of course for
their justification to go there they
exaggerate scare and terrified and so
and so so we know the other ones this is
our society
this is not the fact they are scared
women have
fought hard for their rights in
afghanistan they now can have a
university education they can have a
career they can wear what they want
they can socialize with who they want
but they're terrified of what life may
look like under your rule
and what they stand to lose
what do they stand to lose they will
lose nothing
only they if they had
no hijab they will have a hijab
we should accept each other and
other society should not impose
uh your
culture on us or not we are imposing our
culture on you
culture aside
when it comes to women's rights and
their opportunities and their freedoms
they will lose nothing under your rule
is that what you're saying
right now yes the women
teachers they have resumed the work
lost nothing
the journalists they have presumed
female i i mean female journalists they
have resumed their work lost nothing
we're hearing reports of members of the
taliban going door-to-door looking for
people like journalists like
members of the judiciary former
government workers we're hearing that
girls schools have been closed in some
provinces
what are you doing about that
all fake reports
if anyone is as you say
and we investigate every incident
who is being door-to-door he himself
will be prosecuted and tried and
punished
because that is a violation of our
policy but i can assure you there are
many reports by our opening opponents
claiming uh what is not
based on realities
who aren't leaving their homes because
they're frightened
people can't pay their staff because
they can't access cash people can't buy
food because they can't access their
bank accounts
what is your plan when is life going to
be restored to some sense of normality
for the afghan people
now it is not only hardly a week
that we have taken over
so of course
the initial days
they will have right they are having
this problems but there is need that
this problem will continue
as i said everything will be restored
they will have all
access to all these needs to bank
banks and receiving their salaries
and
everything what is needed and what is
expected for from our government they
will have access to that
and as we now approach the date for
american british
foreign forces soldiers
to leave afghanistan
what would you say to the families of
those
who died trying to help afghanistan
i first of all say
they acquired our country
if we
occupy your country what you will say
to me
i
killed
your people
in your country
what you will say
i think
our people
suffered a lot
bloodshed destruction
everything but
we say the past is
the past story
a part of the our
part of our past history
now we want to focus on future and
future we want cooperation with al-qaeda
countries yes
the passports are very painful
yes but still one thing i say
we were fighting them in our country
and we didn't send
any group
to fight them in their countries while
we had these capabilities because we do
not have foreign agenda i think it was
a mistake a great mistake even at that
time when i was a deputy ambassador in
islam but at that time i told it is a
mistake
this issue should be
resolved through peace
full means and talks
and will be better and
beneficial for both sides